[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture nous allons parler de
justice avec un invité exceptionnel qui
philippe bilger bonjourbonjour noté ni
vol dans notre domaine
on va parler de justice on va pas les
rassurer et on va parler d'un roman qui
est publié en poche aux éditions la joie
ni qui s'appelle 72 heures pour les gens
qui vous ne vous connaîtraient pas je
précise que vous êtes vous êtes un
ancien magistrat vous avez été notamment
avocat général à la cour d'assises de
paris pendant une dizaine d'années et
puis vous êtes un observateur éclairé et
souvent acérées de l'actualité ou parler
de justice vous parlez aussi de
politique on parlera avec vous aussi de
l'actualité judiciaire
et puis de politique mais on va d'abord
parlé de ce roman 72 heures qui paraît
donc en poche vous avez écrit beaucoup
décès sur les utilise sur la politique
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à passer au
roman
eh bien d'abord une ambition démesurée
quand j'étais jeune j'avais des
ambitions très modeste je ne rêvais
d'être marcel proust et vous voyez est
en selle construit rien voilà
actuellement est naturellement vous avez
bien voulu dire j'ai écrit un certain
nombre d'essais
même un livre sur bravia qu mais je
n'avais pas assez d'imagination pour me
lancer dans ce que j'appelle la les
greffes romanesque et heureusement j'ai
pensé un jour à ce sujet qui avait la
structure de la cour d'assises d'arlon
qui n'exigeaient pas forcément une
inventivité folle et j'ai essayé de
restituer l'atmosphère très singulière
d'une cour d'assises
avec les fraternités étrange l'horreur
domestique et la fascination voilà
comment ce roman est arrivé et je
rêverais qu'il ne soit pas le dernier
mais bon on ne sait jamais justement
quand on passe au roman puisque j'avais
beau coup d'essai au niveau du style est
ce que ça change
quelle belle idée très bien écrit le
livre est ce que vous avez fait
particulièrement attention au style jo
je le dire parce que c'est sans doute la
facilité que je me suis donné puisque je
fais parler la cuvée à la première
personne et sans nous comparer à
d'illustrés devanciers il est évident
que j'ai mis beaucoup de bois même dans
dans la cuve et donc je
je reconnais bien volontiers que je n'ai
pas adapté le style à tous les
personnages qui venait même si par maman
et d'antennes le fait un roman qui
s'appelle 72 heures et 72 heures et bien
ce sont les trois jours pendant lesquels
cette cour d'assises qui va qui siègent
elle va juger frédéric loriot qui est ta
cousine accusé d'avoir poussé dans le
vide et tué sa maîtresse
alors on va revenir au titre trois jours
c'est court et 72 heures hé bien c'est
long alors est-ce que vous avez choisi
justement ce titre pour montrer cette
différence entre les trois jours d'un
procès que les gens qui lisent écoute
écoute les comptes rendus judiciaires
comme ça de loin voir ce temps long et
d'un autre côté 72 heures hé bien c'est
pour l'accusé ceux qui vont le juger
ce sont trois jours et trois nuits
qu'ils sont absolument obsédante
sûrement mais ces trois jours et trois
nuits
j'ose le dire obsédante pour tout le
monde
alors bien sûr je ne mettrai pas sur le
même plan l'an boivent parfois de
l'avocat général
ou celle du président ou de la
présidente mais il ne peut pas demeurer
indifférent à au climat très particulier
d'une cour date yves et qui traite
légèrement ce climat particulier doit
faire autre chose dans sa vie judiciaire
il n'est pas convenable de faire une
hiérarchie en cours date yves entre les
affaires prétendument très grave
fm qui ferait anodine à partir du moment
où il ya une atmosphère criminelle elle
dérange à la justice ordinaire
et elle doit j'allais dire oui elles
doivent signer tous ceux qui participent
avec gravité avec intelligence et pas
seulement avec sensibilité
il me semble qu'au sujet de la cour
d'assises on insiste trop sur la
sensibilité et je continue à penser dans
le judiciaire pour la justice elle-même
l'intelligence ne devrait pas ne devrait
pas être une denrée tellement rare
[Musique]
c'est un peu comme dans les procès
maintenant dans le récit de la vie de
l'accusé de la victime donc c'est un
couple à la mode lui frédéric loriot
travaille dans l'événementiel et elle
marie elle est dans l'édition et il
quitte sa femme pour elle alors je vous
le site avec marie ce qui m'est tombé
dessus comme la foudre celle envie de
vivre avec elle elle va l'entraîner dans
des mondes donc il n'aime pas tellement
le sexe la drogue la vie facile au fond
il accepte il est il est fou d'elle
et comme souvent dans un couple il y a
il ya un déséquilibre et le fait est
bien qu'elle ne veuille pas se marier
avec lui le rend dingue
en tout cas l'affaiblît alors on peut
dire que lui tient plus à elle qu'elle
ne tient qu'à lui et il lui fait un
certain nombre de scènes ainsi jaloux
enfin on peut le dire il fait un
caractériel aux fins et pardon je ne
vais pas amélioré mon image léger j'ai
toujours aimé analyser la passion
amoureuse
partant du principe que paradoxalement
une passion pouvait durer et que donc
dans la mesure où elle mène au paroxysme
elle est très intéressante à analyser et
là il est clair que ya ce contraste
entre deux personnalités est un
caractériel peut être passionnément
amoureux et désirait plus que tout
posséder une autre vie le ter ne ferait
pas plaisir à fall qui parle de mitu
mais il y a quelque chose de et j'aime
énormément cette idée que un être c'est
un changement de monde et un changement
de monde parfois fait un être et j'ai
des souvenirs de cours d'assises dans la
tête qui montre à quel point c'était
vrai il ya une chose alors nathalie
rappeler au ghana la biographie au fond
des ddd de l'accusé de ça la victime il
ya toujours quelque chose ça vous savez
tous fascinés ça dans les cours
d'assises c'est vrai qu'on refait la vie
de l'accusé
alors on a l'impression que c'est
quelque chose d'objectif or c'est
toujours analysées en fonction du crime
qui a été commis
moi je me souviens par exemple
un procès d'assises on y va l'accusé dit
oui oui il va s'appeler boire un coup
avec les autres bistrots donc être
distant lointain s'il avait eu au
bistrot on aurait dit saint paul seront
signés ce que je veux dire et est ce que
ça va toujours facile dans le procès
d'assises
et est-ce qu'au fond et la houppe sont
un peu dans votre votre héros et ça me
fait penser un peu aux morceaux de camus
est ce que l'accusé n'est pas toujours
un peu étranger à son procès sûrement et
d'ailleurs je crois me rappeler qu'il le
dit à un moment donné il est très
difficile d'être un bon accusés c'est
clair à moins que et j'essayais de
l'aide du rand bref plus de 20 ans il
faut que l'avocat général soient
conscients de la difficulté des trains
accusaient même quand il veut être de
bonne foi et sincère vous avez
totalement raison
le risque c'est qu'en permanence fois
qu'il adopte comme comportement on le
juge d'un ferr et c'est très dur
donc il faut en permanence que le
président l'avocat général l'avocat de
la partie civile
ça c'est un gros problème aux archives
soient conscients du fait que le désir
de justice ne doit pas entraîner des
inégalités et des injustices c'est à
dire que j'espère avoir été fidèle à ce
dessein qui consistait en permanence à
savoir qu'il était difficile d'être un
accusé qui pouvait même qui disait la
vérité et notamment sur un point que
j'évoque dans le roman le langage c'est
à dire madame de staël disent elles la
parole n'était pas son langage c'est ça
la grande discrimination
objectivement beaucoup plus que la
justice de classe au sens marxiste un
fait s'exprimer les autres seulement
tellement c'est capital et je me
souviens pardon pour cette réponse trop
longue mais souvent j'ai commencé un
réquisitoire aux assises en disant aux
jurés n'ont pu tepa charge
à sept accusés ce qui relève de sa
pauvreté de langage j'en ai connu
certains qui voulait s'excuser du
violent qu'ils avaient commis et qui en
réalité nivelles contraire ils
aggravaient leur cac après parce qu'ils
savaient pas maîtriser le langage le
rappeler tout à l'heure en 72 heures
c'est un roman et est ce que ça vous a
permis de vous amuser un peu avec cette
galerie de portraits moi j'ai beaucoup
apprécié les avocats m'as tu vu certains
magistrats tiré sur deux j'ai beaucoup
aimé cette présidente qui murmure et
qu'on écoute comme dans une salle de
bain comme à la messe et pas dans une
salle d'audience et puis il ya ces
journalistes peu recommandables très
conformiste donc est ce que est ce que
général chamarré comme un comme un
maréchal à vie en effet amusé je me suis
amusé non respect d'un même jeu
jean réussi je violer la réglementation
puisque théoriquement on doit porter la
légion d'honneur sur sa robe
je gérerai trouvé ça presque un peu
provocateur d'espérer convaincre sur la
distinction du thon cheer
l'argumentation mais en effet je ne
jouerai pas l'hypocrite j'avais des
modèles dans la tête
le centriste j'avais des des hommes
politiques dans la tête j'avais un
magistrat dans la tête j'avais des
analystes alors ils sont pas parfois ils
constituent sont mêlés le tube d'une
petite synthe ingénieusement mai mais
j'aime j'ai voulu montrer parfois le
risque de caricatures qui existe dans la
cour d'assises et donc je me suis amusé
à faire des portraits parfois change et
certains s'en sont reconnus peut-être
nous en veulent pas de joie à la sortie
du livre
à l'inversé les questions que vous vous
posez pas puisque quand vous êtes passés
au roman dans cette histoire c'est la
fin puisque la dramaturgie de une cour
d'assises c'est en effet le vernis donc
il ya le suspense il est il à la fin
alors ya en effet c'est la portance des
jurés dans tendance dans ce roman est
dans la justice criminelle
même si certains français maintenant on
va s'en passer
qu'est ce que vous en pensez d'ailleurs
dans le cas je trouve c'est une
catastrophe je veux dire c'est à fait
français
quand on a une structure une institution
qui marche
j'allais dire à la perfection ce vrai
trop dire mais qui marche bien
la juridiction qui menait grâce à la
présence du peuple était une réussite
eh bien on la chance on la dgrad c'est
hallucinant de voir ça dans tous les
domaines le biton un des grands
revenants de l'investissement on confie
tout ça est venue de l'emprise des
d'avocats sur la corde hâtives et on a
considéré trop vite que dès qu'un grand
avocat perdre un procès c'était une
erreur judiciaire
en ce qui me confère une fana on abuse
de la notion d' erreur judiciaire
on confond peut-être des interprétations
discutable dans le cadre d'un procès
avec la véritable erreur judiciaire qui
consiste à poursuivre ou à condamner
quelqu'un dont on sait qu'il n'est pas
coupable parce qu'on a retrouvé le
véritable auteur
moi je considère que les longtemps les
les citoyens c'est un plus considérable
en matière de gnl et on a créé une
procédure pour eux c'est cela qui est
fondamental la cour d'assises a été créé
pour eux avec l'oralité des débats mais
mais pendant longtemps comme annoncé en
fin de contrat de nettoyage notamment de
magistrats
voyez bien que les eurent été souvent
sous la coupe de prison vous dites que
c'est de moins en moins vrai alors
probablement en province sont qui est
l'ombre d'une nuance péjorative
la province en attendant les
représentants du parquet viennent de
manière un peu conjoncturel soutenir
l'accusation il ya des présidents qui
ont plus d'expérience qui probablement
ont une emprise trop forte et peut-être
trop de condescendance sur les jeunes
magistrats du parquet méheut dans là je
dirai dans la structure parisienne dans
l'île de france
je ne crois pas que ça ait changé ça
n'existe plus sur les durées sur les
sûrs et vous savez les jurés aujourd'hui
et depuis un certain temps ne sont plus
ces jurés qui était choisi par les
maires et le système a changé en 75 ils
ont été pris sur les listes électorales
on leur ferait plus avaler n'importe
quoi et donc c'est le rôle de l'avocat
général qui est rendu plus difficile
parce qu'au lieu de pouvoir espérer
convaincre une globalité de jure et un
drop ou prou accordé avec sa conception
de la répression et de la société
on a des individualités qu'il faut
convaincre
tour à tour et donc je considère que le
le jury criminel est une chose est
inestimable dans la hiérarchie la plus
grave des transferts
on va parler un tout petit peu de vous
d'autant que magistrat vous avez
commencé comme juge d'instruction et lui
ensuite vous avez choisi le parquet pour
que vous avez changé alors d'abord je ne
j'ai cherché à le dire tout à l'heure je
rêvais d'être écrivain je déteste le
droit j'ai et mais vraiment et ça n'est
pas mais je déteste droit et j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir dans ma vie julie fier
d'eux justive de luxe la liberté
d'expression qui est du byzantinisme
intellectuelle et plus de vingt ans aux
assises où la culture générale la
culture littéraire pouvait se substituer
aux droits parce que en cours d'être
subversif au fait que de droit très peu
d'eau il ya trois notions que les jurés
ont du mal à
comprendre intention homicide complicité
et tentatives
le rêve c'est de la culture générale et
bien sûr ça a été merveilleux pont pas
qu'ils aient pu aborder toutes ces
réalités criminelles et la liberté
d'expression par le biais littéraire et
donc j'aurais été amenés à exercer de
véritables fonctions appelant une
technique comme vous probablement un
sablar considérable je n'aurais je
n'aurais pas et quand on n'a ni rester
comme ça une dizaine d'années comme
avocat général à la cour d'assises
quelle vision de l'humanité ce qu'on ne
peut plus de 20 ans dont plus de 20 ans
non mais plus de vingt ans alors je
crois que j'avais un tempérament et j'ai
un tempérament naturellement pessimiste
oui effectivement mais peut-être que la
cour d'assises a favorisé ou font ce
développement mais en même temps quand
on est magistrat
pour être cohérent on ne peut pas
exercer ce métier si on croit pas un
petit peu à la possibilité de rédemption
comme disait scott fitzgerald il
faudrait au moins faire comme si c'était
possible et donc bizarrement la réalité
judiciaire a introduit dans mon maître
un peu d'optimisme
je pense qu'il y a des accusés qui sont
absolument pas rachetables par long mais
qui sont très très rares mais la plupart
et bien évidemment je tentais de les
regarder de les appréhender comme si
demain il y avait une possibilité de
rédemption et que leurs protestations
j'ai compris à un cour d'assises pouvait
être perçu comme de la sincérité
parmi les nombreux procès dans lesquels
vous êtes intervenu on pourrait citer
bien sûr françois bès le complice de
mesrine emile louis le gang des barbares
est-ce qu'il y en a un qui vous a marqué
plus que d'autres alors
les très grands il y à des procès qui
m'ont marqué mais qui n'était absolument
pas médiatisé des crimes j'allais dire
intrafamiliaux ils sont passionnants ils
sont très durs ils sont l'incandescent
il y en a d'autres
les j'allais dire les profs et ordinaire
si j'ose dire et adjectif aucun n'est
indifférent par honnête et puis il ya
une catégorie très rare de prophètes
vous avez un peu évoqué où on ne fait
pas un procès contre la cuvée mais d'une
certaine manière avec lui parce qu'il
maîtrise tellement bien longue à rj que
il m'est arrivé qu'on serrait que le
président était superfétatoire à la
limite j'aurais volontiers continuer le
dialogue à la baisse mais il y en a
d'autres et d'une certaine manière
brunerie hélène castel eux parce que ces
gens sans celui qui avait voulu tirer
sur certains suggérant qui maîtrise du
langage capacité d' analyse et baisse en
particulier puisqu'il allait même plus
loin que l'accusation dans la
détestation du climat de l'époque où
faisaient de lui avec mesrine une sorte
de robin des bois idéologique alors que
c'est elle il avait compris que c'était
quelque chose d'odieux cette image qu'on
prétendait projeter sur lui la gauche
sylvain qui voyaient dans n'importe
quelle transgression une scie version
positive et vous écrivez aussi beaucoup
sur la justice mme dans d'envolées de
bien sûr mais aussi dans votre blog
justice au singulier que vous étiez
trois frères qui ont très bien réussi
tous les trois et qui paraît-il quand il
était enfant voulait devenir ministre
auriez vous aimé être garde des sceaux a
way
vous êtes très aimable de poser cette
question ça me fera jamais que la 201e
fois comme la demande
je réponds à chaque cela avec une
absolue sans fériés j'aurais j'aurais
adoré être ministre et on sachant en
même temps que c'était inconcevable vous
voyez on peut répondre avec une totale
bonne foi et en même temps savoir mais
il est évident que d'abord les ministres
depuis 2007 ne nous on compte pas
complètement rendue tellement modeste
face à leurs prestations
et puis ensuite parce que c'est tout
même on a beau dire c'est tout même le
lieu et la fonction où on peut faire le
plus de choses là il ya eu peu de
magistrats finalement dans les années
récentes au garde des sceaux
il ya eu des avocats lieu robert ban
atteint il ya dupond-moretti aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de dupond
moretti comme garde des sceaux alors
dupond-moretti mais je n'en parle pas
dans personnel contre lui à cause de ma
fille charlotte qui est magistrat mais
je laisse ça de côté
c'est une faune c'est une fausse bonne
idée dit pont murray dit je dirais c'est
un coût qui a été fait par emmanuel
macron je crois sur le conseil de son
épouse et il y à des coûts qui ont été
faits par d'autres présidents mais il me
semble qu'ils avaient du sens à les
choisir un avocat au demeurant très
brillant aux à fives
mais qui à détester profondément la
magistrature jean fils témoin j'étais
l'un de ses rares amis dans la
magistrature et jeu je trouve que c'est
une provocation totalement inutile et
donc on comprend bien qu'il a été choisi
non pas pour être un véritable ministre
de la justice
mais pour servir d'extraordinaire
brodeur lors de la campagne
présidentielle con
marine le pen éventuellement contre
d'autres avec cette ambiguïté moi qui me
choque sur le plan républicain qu'on
peut à la fois être sur une liste aux
régionales et en même temps de me rennes
les listes à lire choisir de servir deux
maîtres qui me semble radicalement
différents mais justement dans les
réactions des magistrats david dupont
moretti
il n'ya pas quand même un peu de
corporatisme sûrement mais il y en a
aussi beaucoup chez les dames au cas les
jeunes non mais vraiment je trouve que
dupont moretti pour rester dans le
programme judiciaire elle devenue
clairement de mon point de vue le
ministre des dames au 15 mai mais chez
les magistrats
chez les magistrats bien content quand
on lui reproche par exemple d'avoir
défendu telle et telle personne âgée
aujourd hui il faudrait prendre un
avocat qui n'a jamais voyagé mais plaidé
pour qui que ce soit vous avez tout à
fait raison
reste qu'on pouvait peut-être si on
souhaitait un avocat prendre un avocat
qui rendrait moins difficile la gestion
ministérielle puisque vous le savez jean
castex qui a découvert tout en cause
judiciaire a été obligé de traiter
certaines des affaires 230 à matignon et
après seulement on va parler des
réformes
un petit peu quand même aujourd'hui on
vote à l'assemblée donc sur l'eau sur la
confiance assure la confiance à leur
confiance pourquoi cette c'est pourquoi
quand aussi cette confiance at elle été
rompues confiance entre les citoyens et
leurs institutions évidemment et
certains dénoncent le laxisme la justice
notamment
aujourd'hui les policiers
alors que faut-il penser tout ça alors
là la confiance entre le citoyen et
l'institution judiciaire
je ne dirais pas qu'elles aient rompu
mais il faut travailler sur elle mais et
femmes pourraient venir d'abord que de
la part de l'univers judiciaire et des
magistrats eux-mêmes qui devrait traiter
comment dire avec moins de prouver sans
danse le citoyen le citoyen lorsqu'il
faut qu'une de la réalité judiciaire
s'occupe de ce qui le regarde et il y a
parfois de la part d'un certain nombre
de magistrats
la méconnaissance du fait que s'ils
donnent fondamentalement la légitimité à
la magistrature celle citoyens et donc
on doit satisfaire autant qu'on peut ses
attentes ses jeux d'hier ses espérances
et j'ai pas l'impression je n'ai pas
l'impression que la magistrature est
suffisamment confiante de cela parce
qu'au fond ça devrait on off seule
ambition rendre une justice la plus
rapide possible la plus efficace
possible
la plus équitable possible en offrant
aux citoyens en permanence une forme un
langage qui montre qu'on le reste non
amène bien sûr parler quand même la
question des moyens parce qu'on est
quand même dans un pays dont le budget
de la justice est un des plus faibles au
monde
oui mais je ne voudrais pas et je vous
rejoins fille j'ai bien compris vos
interrogations
je ne voudrais pas que la question des
moyens soins en permanence la libye
c'est à dire on aura jamais un moment
dans notre vie démocratique où on aura
des syndicats on aura des magistrats qui
viendront dire ah ben là on assez moyen
c'est impeccable avoir travaillé non il
faut faire les deux il faut à la fois
avoir un syndicalisme non politisés qui
réclame des moyens des crédits pourquoi
pas mais en même temps continuer à
travailler
et d'arrache-pied parce qu'on peut tout
de même continuer à travailler
d'arrache-pied
même si on n'a pas tous les moyens qu'on
espère c'est ça le problème dans la
magistrature il ne faut pas que les
moyens deviennent une sorte de deux
remèdes pour expliquer une forme
d'impuissance qui ne dépend que de nous
oui c'est vrai que toute cette actualité
nous ramène à votre livre quand on
referme
moi j'ai trouvé bien sûr n'a pas raconté
la fin mais pas comme ça une impression
mélancolie presque de ce triste est que
que géo conac on a recent tenir tous les
2 patrice et ont l'impression que en
fond quelle que soit la solution en
somme il ya un sentiment d'imperfections
d'injustice même des hommes et de
bunkers parfaite
est ce que l'un et l'autre totalement
raison et fait la grande différence
entre la justice française et la justice
anglo saxon anglo saxon est vrai ce
qu'on a pu démontrer ce qui est prouvé
dans notre conception française on a une
ambition bien au delà elle est presque
métaphysique
ce qui fait qu'en réalité même dans les
procès les plus réussis on peut avoir le
sentiment d'une petite déception on
voudrait sonder le coeur et les reins
il y a toujours un mystère après l'arrêt
de condamnation ou d'acquittement et
c'est ce qui crée une déception mais est
ce une déception est simplement la
parfaite lucidité qu'on a sur les
labyrinthes de l'être peut-être que
finalement c'est ni l'optimisme ni le
pessimisme et le rien c'est la réalité
mais c'est comme ça qu'on n'accuse pas
forcément au désespoir
merci infiniment merci chers jeunes
prennent donc la question d'une grande
pertinence le livre 72 heures roman
judiciaire mais pas que c'est en poche
aux éditions la joie ni et puis vous
êtes invités quand vous voulez un pour
en parler parce qu'il est plein de
sujets qu'on aurait pu accueillir oui à
toutes les invitations
merci infiniment merci
[Musique]